it's time for a pride parade family is  marching four by four hurray hurray  families marching four by four hurray  trans members of this family all love  each other so proudly and they all go  marching in the big parade this by the  way is a show for preschoolers okay like  uh like three-year-olds  pushing drag queens and pansexuals do  you know what a typical plot for Blues  Clues used to be Steve who it was the  guy  that he would lose his glue stick  and he'd have to find it and he would  ask blue hey blue do you know where my  glue stick is and blue would be all uh  Coy about it even though blue knows what  the damn glue stick is he won't just  tell Steve where it is so he starts  planting all these Clues around the  house and at the end he finds it  that's the end of the show and now we  have  um pansexual toads and bisexual Turtles  singing about their favorite sexual  orientation so a little bit of a  different approach I suppose